Jennifer Lawrence here she is saying  that before her there were no chicks  doing lead acting roles in action movies  I think she may have a limited memory I  remember when I was doing Hunger Games  nobody had ever put a woman in the lead  of an action movie because it wouldn't  work we were told  [Music]  you [ __ ] girls and boys can both  identify with a male lead but boys  cannot identify with a female lead oh  absolutely  nobody had ever put a woman in the lead  of an action movie  because it wouldn't work  congrats Jennifer Lawrence you just  erased all of those chicks unless she  knows something we don't know maybe she  knows they all have penises in which  case they're still chicks right isn't  that how this thing works it's also  confusing